a new house of the dragon teaser just
dropped so spoilers ahead let's get
right into it nope this isn't daenerys
targaryen a black robe white-haired
woman overlooking the shores of what
appears to be dragonstone the same place
daenerys will take control of 200 years
later this is rhaenyra targaryen the
only child of viserys the first who
currently sits on the iron throne as
lord of the seven kingdoms as we'll see
throughout the trailer we'll have both
young and older versions of herself so
this story will last several years here
we have an establishing shot on the
tumultuous shores of dragonstone which
you can make out in the background the
voiceover makes reference to legacy
which seems to be one of the major
themes of house of the dragon and it
makes sense considering many of the
bloodlines we'll see in this trailer
will continue on in a song of fire and
ice you'll recognize this place as the
steps leading up to dragonstone where we
have prince daemon targaryen holding a
dragon egg to his left is masseria a
confidante and unofficial mistress to
the prince and it looks like a trade is
happening here the dragon egg in
exchange for daemon and mysterious baby
this scene sets up the ongoing feud
between prince damon and current hand of
the king sir otto hightower prince damon
believes he's the rightful heir to the
throne should his older brother king
viserys not produce a male heir but sir
otto hightower believes that if this
does not happen the role should fall to
viserys's daughter rhaenyra so already
we have a lot of jostling for power when
it comes to who controls the throne to
otto's left appears to be knight of the
kingsguard creston cole he becomes a far
more pivotal character later on in the
series and check out a totally not
burned to the ground king's landing you
can even make out the great septa bailor
over to the left it's tough to make out
but this looks like it could be prince
demon riding the dragon known as karaxis
but if it's rhaenyra then it's her and
her dragon cyrax well it's just like
we're home again in the great hall of
king's landing where king viserys sits
on his throne with several ancestors of
known houses pledging their allegiance
among them the starks who we actually
don't get to see corliss of house
valerian and bormond of house baratheon
king viserys stands watch holding one of
two ancestral targaryen blades i think
this is blackfire but it could be its
companion blade the dark sister another
big difference you'll notice here are
the amount of blades surrounding the
throne from my research it appears this
was done to make the throne more in line
with the books but it also serves to
show just how powerful and intimidating
the current ruler is compared to say a
robert baratheon or those who came after
him here we get a look at young rhaenyra
targaryen where it is confirmed she has
been named heir to the throne which when
you realize this next shot is of daemon
looking pretty pissed you can see how
this season will be a power struggle
between these two camps at least for a
bit and damon wastes no time taking out
his anger on the citizens of king's
landing this might take place in flea
bottom and not sure if this season will
cover it but damon will become commander
of the city watch so this may also
depict that this is princess reynus
targaryen she tells rhaenyra that some
men would rather see the city burn than
have a woman rule kinda ironic since a
woman ruler will end up literally
burning the city back at dragonstone
rhaenyra overlooks the painted table of
westeros just like daenerys will 200
years later notice the blade here i
wonder if it's the same one her father
was holding in the throne room that
might even be raynus in the background
clad in armor it appears as though some
war meeting was held as you can see
various markers on the map now this
looks like it could be the ruined halls
of harrenhal where the lords of the
seven kingdoms vote on who will succeed
the throne after the sudden death of
bale and targaryen we've actually seen
these runes in season 2 of game of
thrones this event actually takes place
before viserys ends up as king and if we
were to go on birth order alone uranus
should have taken over as queen this is
why she's also known as the queen who
never was since she's passed over on
account of her being a woman so
therefore viserys ends up as king here
we have alison's hightower daughter to
the hand of the king arriving at a large
feast and kissing viserys on the cheek
she will later become second wife to the
king a dragon egg over hot coals keeping
it warm before hatching luckily the same
egg damon was holding earlier in the
trailer back to sir otto hightower here
we can see him clearly wearing that hand
of the king a pin he tells his daughter
that they both play an ugly game
alluding to the game of thrones and that
they can actually win it so it looks
like he's pimping his daughter to get
her with the king joining the party is
corliss valerian who i should mention is
married to rayness and here is daemon
off to the side of the end table smugly
watching the night's festivities he
might even be watching rainier dancing
with a valerian we don't see his face
but this might be corliss's son lenore
who becomes ranera's first husband and
this might even be their wedding this is
a marriage of convenience which would
unite the targaryen and valerian houses
but we'll learn that lenore is more into
sexy young squires than he is with women
i just hope the people celebrating here
aren't celebrating a wedding because we
know how those turn out in game of
thrones but guess who becomes rhinera's
second husband it's damon so it looks
like this teaser is setting up all this
stuff taking a darker turn we have a
funeral where a stone casket is dropped
into the sea notice the house valerian
sigils off to the side to me this
appears to be a woman's casket in the
wide shot here you can see what might be
cordless valerian pushing the casket
into the ocean so it's likely someone
from his family maybe his daughter lena
this shot of older rhaenyra seems to
take place at this funeral as she's
wearing the same red dress found in the
wide shot this one of allison and
creston cole may also be from the scene
but we can't be a hundred percent sure
now this shot has been causing quite a
stir as debates have sprung up if this
is either aegon ii or daemon targaryen i
happen to think this is daemon where
he's brought to the king where he'll
later be exiled for having sex with
rhaenyra but let me know in the comments
what you think crest and coal here going
absolute ham on some poor soul and check
out this blood pact followed by a shot
of daemon and renera looks like this is
them getting married here we have otto
hightower once again at dragonstone with
damon holding the egg preparing for
battle this is followed by alison
attempting to murder rhaenyra with the
cat's paw dagger now the cat's pod
dagger has a huge history in the world
of westeros being passed down from
various famous characters you might
remember it as being the dagger that
almost killed bran stark in season 1 of
game of thrones if i were to hazard a
guess this is alison trying to exact
some sort of revenge on rhaenyra our
final shot is of damon uncovering a
dragon and i don't think we nor daemon
really knows which dragon this is he
looks pretty shocked for someone who's
supposed to be able to control them
maybe this is the dragon that hatched
from that egg years later but i want to
know what you think not only about the
egg but the entire season i'm planning
to cover the whole series once it comes
out so make sure you like and subscribe
so you'll be notified as soon as one of
my videos drops thanks for watching for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at think story yt
until next time remember nobody thought
of that he's bringing all the dead
people back to life and they put the
women and children
in a [ __ ] with all the dead people so
crawl